Shure: yes
Shure: Yes
Jake: 开始吧开始吧
Jake: Let's start, let's start
Shure:  能对一下那什么吗
Shure: Can we check that thing?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 大家互相看一下谁的红灯
Jake: Everyone, check whose red light is on
Jake: 白灯没有亮就是
Jake: If the white light isn't on, then...
Katrina: 亮了
Katrina: It's on
Shure: 都亮了
Shure: All lights are on
Jake: 亮了很亮很亮
Jake: It's on, very bright
Jake: 来看一会
Jake: Let's watch for a bit
Lucia: OK
Jake: 好看吗
Jake: Looks good?
Shure:  好看
Shure: Looks good
Shure:  太棒了
Shure: Awesome
Jake: 好看
Jake: Looks good
Alice: 好看
Alice: Looks good
Jake: 好看
Jake: Looks good
Shure:  来给AI喂点抖音
Shure: Let's feed the AI some TikTok
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Tasha: 自己想看
Tasha: Wants to watch it itself
Jake: 这谁啊
Jake: Who's this?
Shure: 陈泽啊
Shure: It's Chen Ze
Katrina:  呵呵陈泽有点抽象真的
Katrina: Haha, Chen Ze is kind of abstract, really
Jake: 天天小考
Jake: Everyday quizzes
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh no
Jake:哎呦 卧槽
Jake: Oh, damn
Jake:沙雕
Jake: Idiot
Shure: 成谢谢您
Shure: Alright, thank you
Jake: 唉 客气好好嘞
Jake: Ah, you're welcome, it's all good
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh no
Shure:  掉出来了
Shure: It fell out
Jake: 哎呀怎么掉出来了
Jake: Oh no, how did it fall out?
Shure:  哎
Shure: Oh
Lucia: 好谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thank you
Katrina: 呀好热呀
Katrina: Oh, it's so hot
Katrina:  感觉比武汉还热呀
Katrina: Feels hotter than Wuhan
Shure:  不知道
Shure: No idea
Alice:公主请下车哎呦
Alice: Princess, please get off the car, oh no
Lucia: 司机先下车
Lucia: Driver, get off first
Lucia: 然后给你把门拉开这种
Lucia: Then open the door for you, like this
Tasha: 浪费下车
Tasha: Waste of time getting off
Shure:  万一遇刺什么的是吧
Shure: What if we get attacked, right?
Jake: 对第一个下车第一个被崩
Jake: Yeah, the first one to get off is the first one to get hit.
Shure: 第一个下了之后喽
Shure: After the first one gets off...
Shure:  保镖
Shure: Bodyguard.
Jake: 怎么过去啊
Jake: How do we get over there?
Jake: 怎么停在这么个地方啊
Jake: Why did we stop here?
Katrina: 怎么过去
Katrina: How do we get there?
Tasha: 跨过去
Tasha: Step over it.
Shure: 我们只要
Shure: We just need to...
Jake: 你跨一下
Jake: You step over it.
Lucia: 助跑一下哈哈哈
Lucia: Take a running start, haha.
Shure:  迟到了
Shure: We're late.
Shure:  这怎么给停这地方
Shure: Why did we stop here?
Lucia: 我好像有一点点晕
Lucia: I feel a little dizzy.
Shure:  给差评
Shure: Give it a bad rating.
Jake: 给差评
Jake: Give it a bad rating.
Jake: 咋整啊
Jake: What should we do?
Jake: 那边是可以走吗
Jake: Can we walk that way?
Shure: 过去
Katrina:  盒马在这个商场里吗
Katrina: Is Hema in this mall?
Jake:那那那过得去吗
Jake: Can we get through there?
Jake: 过不去
Jake: Can't get through.
Tasha: 盒马在哪
Tasha: Where's Hema?
Jake: 绕一圈吧
Jake: Let's take a detour.
Katrina: 搜一下
Katrina: Search it up.
Shure:  啊从那过去
Shure: Go through there.
Tasha: 真的可以过去的
Tasha: We can really get through.
Shure: 盒马
Shure: Hema.
Lucia: 那个有点高吧感觉跨不过去啊
Lucia: That looks pretty high, I don't think we can step over it.
Jake: 头盔要不给他吧
Jake: Should we give him the helmet?
Tasha: 我伤心了
Tasha: I'm sad now.
Tasha: 不用了
Tasha: Never mind.
Tasha: 我真的伤心了
Tasha: I'm really sad now.
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What should I do?
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where's everyone?
Tasha: 我的钻石掉了
Tasha: My diamond fell off.
Alice: 底下那个底掉了没法往上弄了
Alice: The bottom part fell off, can't fix it now.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:不闪了
Alice: It's not shining anymore.
Jake:就翻的时候掉了是吗
Jake: Did it fall when you flipped it?
Jake:这唱的还挺好
Jake: The singing is pretty good.
Jake:来带大家看看这个
Jake: Let's show everyone this.
Jake:北京大超市
Jake: Beijing's big supermarket.
Alice:这吧
Alice: Over here.
Jake: 他们已经上去了
Jake: They've already gone up.
Tasha: 为什么不等我们
Tasha: Why didn't they wait for us?
Jake: 这么快的
Jake: So fast.
Tasha: 好丑呀
Tasha: So ugly.
Jake:好惨呀
Jake: So sad.
Jake: 他们是上去了
Jake: They went up.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Jake: 这怎么上来这么快啊
Jake: How did they get up so fast?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你们怎么已经到了啊
Lucia: How did you guys get here so fast?
Jake: 我们还找你们呢
Jake: We were still looking for you.
Jake: 怎么丢了呀
Jake: How did you get lost?
Katrina:  系了个鞋带而已
Katrina: Just tying a shoelace.
Shure:  我们我们跟着轩导的步伐来着
Shure: We were following the director's pace.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh right.
Jake: 殊途同归
Jake: All roads lead to Rome.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Katrina:  柯达照相
Katrina: Kodak photos.
Alice:没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Tasha: 一下跑了好远坐着
Tasha: Ran so far to sit down.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's fine.
Tasha: 伤心
Tasha: I'm sad.
Alice:买一套工具自己做
Alice: Buy a set of tools and do it yourself.
Tasha: 早知道不翻了
Tasha: Shouldn't have flipped it.
Alice: 这翻掉了
Alice: It fell when flipping.
Alice:看啥呢
Alice: What are you looking at?
Tasha: 看你的小猫眼
Tasha: Looking at your cat's eyes.
Alice: 哈哈哈小猫眼
Alice: Hahaha, cat's eyes.
Alice: 笑死了
Alice: So funny.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Alice: 啊什么是小猫眼
Alice: What are cat's eyes?
Tasha: 试送了一个专业
Tasha: Trying to be professional.
Alice: 我不知道哎
Alice: I don't know.
Alice: 啥是小猫眼
Alice: What's cat's eyes?
Tasha: 就是眼睛像猫的那种眼睛一样
Tasha: It's when eyes look like a cat's eyes.
Tasha: 很翘
Tasha: Very perky.
Tasha: 然后有几根是那样很
Tasha: And then there are a few that are really...
Shure:  花活特多
Shure: So many tricks.
Alice:很长的
Alice: Very long.
Alice: 感觉这个是通向天堂的
Alice: Feels like this is leading to heaven.
Jake: 这是啥地方
Jake: What is this place?
Alice: 找到一双长睫毛的大眼睛哎
Alice: Found a pair of big eyes with long eyelashes.
Alice: 找到了在那
Alice: Found it, over there.
Lucia: 不好意思又踩到你了
Lucia: Sorry, I stepped on you again.
Shure:  哎呦sorry sorry
Shure: Oops, sorry, sorry.
Tasha: sorry
Tasha: Sorry.
Katrina:  海澜之家
Katrina: Hailan Home.
Katrina:  海澜之家就在我们家旁边
Katrina: Hailan Home is right next to our house.
Tasha: 在甜甜圈中找到一块饼干
Tasha: Found a cookie in the donut.
Jake: 这得多瞎啊
Jake: How blind is that?
Jake: 他看不到啊
Jake: He can't see it.
Alice: 还有呢
Alice: And what else?
Alice: 怎么有股有毒的味道
Alice: Why does it smell like poison?
Tasha: 用这个眼镜去测试你看
Tasha: Use these glasses to test, look.
Tasha: 做测试这
Tasha: Do the test here.
Lucia: 感觉刚装修完似得
Lucia: Feels like it was just renovated.
Tasha: 在车站中找到海澜之家
Tasha: Found Hailan Home at the station.
Alice: 哦原来在这等着我们呢
Alice: Oh, so it was waiting for us here.
Alice: 软广
Alice: Product placement.
Tasha: 我靠还真没找着
Tasha: Damn, couldn't find it.
Jake: 怎么找啊
Jake: How do we find it?
Jake: 海澜之家是啥啊
Jake: What is Hailan Home?
Alice:海澜之家
Alice: Hailan Home.
Lucia: 就是一个卖男装的品牌
Lucia: It's a brand that sells men's clothes.
Jake: 海澜之家
Jake: Hailan Home.
Jake:那他是什么
Jake: So what is it?
Katrina: 海澜之家的总工厂就在我们家旁边的镇上
Katrina: The main factory of Hailan Home is in the town next to our house.
Jake: 找他的logo吗
Jake: Look for its logo?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Jake: 他logo是什么样的
Jake: What does its logo look like?
Katrina: 江阴市
Katrina: Jiangyin City.
Alice: 有嘛区别呢
Alice: Does it make a difference?
Alice:让AI来找一下
Alice: Let AI find it.
Lucia: 怎么觉得没有都一样啊
Lucia: Why do I feel like there's no difference?
Katrina: 二楼
Katrina: Second floor.
Jake:都不知道要找什么
Jake: I have no idea what to look for.
Tasha: 难度可能是进阶的
Tasha: Maybe the difficulty is advanced.
Alice: 他可能就是
Alice: He might be...
Jake:他应该
Jake: He should...
Alice: 为了给你留下一个深刻的印象
Alice: Trying to leave a deep impression on you.
Jake:可能他就没有
Jake: Maybe he just didn't...
Tasha: 然后就一直在找海澜
Tasha: And kept looking for Hailan.
Jake:对一个一个找
Jake: Yeah, looking one by one.
Alice: 然后你就特别特别想知道
Alice: And you really, really want to know...
Alice: 海澜之家到底长啥样
Alice: What Hailan House looks like.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 然后他的目的就达到了
Alice: Then his goal is achieved.
Alice:是这样吗
Alice: Is that so?
Jake: 所以应该长啥样
Jake: So what should it look like?
Katrina: 然后我们之前初中就会去参观
Katrina: We used to visit during middle school.
Alice: 我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Jake: 海澜之家是自己有个logo是长这样吗
Jake: Does Hailan House have a logo that looks like this?
Jake: 还是啥呀
Jake: Or what?
Alice: 海澜之家
Alice: Hailan House.
Lucia: 他logo长啥样啊
Lucia: What does their logo look like?
Alice: 我就记得一个h一个l他们家的门面
Alice: I just remember an "H" and an "L" on their storefront.
Jake:他logo长啥样不知道哇
Jake: What does their logo look like, no idea.
Lucia: 啊好像是
Lucia: Ah, maybe it is.
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Lucia: 不了解因为因为咱们平常也不买男装
Lucia: I don't know because we usually don't buy men's clothes.
Alice:我觉得 里面就是没有我感觉都一样
Alice: I think inside, everything looks the same.
Jake: 对我也不买男装
Jake: Yeah, I don't buy men's clothes either.
Tasha: 那他穿什么
Tasha: Then what does he wear?
Alice:怪怪的
Alice: That's weird.
Jake: 就这个哈哈哈哈
Jake: Just this, hahaha.
Lucia: 女装
Lucia: Women's clothes.
Lucia: 淘宝T恤啊你穿
Lucia: Taobao T-shirts, that's what you wear.
Tasha: 你看喜茶标志很明显
Tasha: Look, the Xi Cha logo is very obvious.
Jake: 这个确实哎
Jake: That's true, yeah.
Lucia: 那可能是上面确实有个标志只是没找到
Lucia: Maybe there's a logo but we just didn't find it.
Tasha: 还测吗哈哈
Tasha: Are we still testing, haha?
Alice: 这有一股有毒的味道
Alice: This place has a toxic smell.
Alice: 感觉在这闻久了要晕倒
Alice: Staying here too long makes you dizzy.
Lucia: +1
Lucia:有种没装修完的
Lucia: It feels like it's unfinished.
Tasha: 是两位男生推购物车吗
Tasha: Are the two guys pushing the shopping carts?
Jake:行啊
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 推两辆是吗
Tasha: Pushing two carts, right?
Jake: 行啊没问题
Jake: Yeah, no problem.
Tasha: 一一边采购酒一边采购食材是吗
Tasha: One cart for buying alcohol and the other for groceries, right?
Jake: 呃啊酒要单独一个车吧
Jake: Uh, yeah, alcohol needs its own cart.
Jake: 推个小的
Jake: Push a small one.
Lucia: 还有小的
Lucia: There's a small one?
Lucia: 啊太小了推起来不好推
Lucia: Ah, it's too small, it's hard to push.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Tasha: 有那个小把手
Tasha: It has a small handle.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Lucia: 这就是小孩推的意思吗
Lucia: Is this meant for kids to push?
Jake: 哦是
Jake: Oh, yes.
Lucia: 是把小孩放在里面推小孩的意思吗
Lucia: Does that mean you put a kid inside and push?
Tasha: 是让小孩推这个车的意思
Tasha: It means kids push this cart.
Alice:是让小孩推得
Alice: It's for kids to push.
Jake: 小孩应该也进不去
Jake: Kids probably can't even fit in there.
Jake: 这得是
Jake: This has to be...
Lucia: 不会是把小孩放在里面
Lucia: You don't put kids in it?
Jake:猫
Tasha: 这这小孩
Tasha: This, this kid...
Alice:坐这
Alice: Sit here.
Jake: 请
Jake: Please.
Tasha: 谁
Tasha: Who?
Alice:请
Alice: Please.
Tasha: 谁
Tasha: Who?
Jake: 都行啊
Jake: Anyone's fine.
Shure:  我能上吗
Shure: Can I get in?
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: 算了
Shure: Never mind.
Jake: 给你推货
Jake: I'll push the goods for you.
Jake: 给你推冰柜去
Jake: I'll push the freezer for you.
Jake: 就那个水产
Jake: Just the seafood.
Tasha: 西瓜
Tasha: Watermelon.
Alice:西瓜
Alice: Watermelon.
Tasha: 买二得三
Tasha: Buy two, get three.
Alice: 榴莲怎么这么便宜
Alice: Why is durian so cheap?
Alice: 是不是该下了
Alice: Shouldn't it be off-season?
Tasha: 有人不爱吃榴莲吗
Tasha: Does anyone not like durian?
Jake: 我可以吃
Jake: I can eat.
Alice:没有吧
Alice: No, right?
Lucia: 不是很爱
Lucia: Not really fond of it.
Shure:  怎么说咱们是分头行动
Shure: How about we split up?
Lucia: 但没事你想吃的话
Lucia: But it's fine if you want to eat.
Shure:  还是一起行动
Shure: Or we can stick together.
Shure:  你把那个图po到那里吧
Shure: You can post that picture there.
Jake: 我们有分工吗
Jake: Do we have specific tasks?
Katrina: 发群里吗
Katrina: Post it in the group?
Jake: 我们分几个路啊
Jake: How many routes do we have?
Shure: 对图po群里
Shure: Yes, post the picture in the group.
Alice: 分几个路啊
Alice: How many routes do we have?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Jake: 其实我们戴着这个眼镜
Jake: Actually, with these glasses,
Jake: 绕着一圈就重建了
Jake: we can walk around and reconstruct it.
Jake: 就是这个整个商场商场就3D重建了
Jake: The whole mall will be reconstructed in 3D.
Tasha: 场景
Tasha: The scene.
Shure: 所以那天
Shure: So that day...
Jake: 就一个赛博盒马
Jake: It's like a cyber Hema.
Shure:  让我哈哈哈
Shure: made me laugh a lot.
Tasha: 没有网哎 你记得吗
Tasha: There was no internet, remember?
Jake: 每个角落走一圈
Jake: Walk around every corner.
Katrina: 我发了
Katrina: I posted it.
Shure:  会怎么样
Shure: What will happen?
Katrina: 那就分
Katrina: Then let's split up.
Katrina:  分其实5-10就是你们买菜啊
Katrina: Split actually 5-10, you guys go buy groceries.
Katrina:  生活用品的那种地方
Katrina: For daily necessities and stuff.
Katrina:  可以你们那就分两拨
Katrina: You guys can split into two groups.
Tasha: 那就5-11呗
Tasha: Then it's 5-11.
Jake: 分两拨分两拨
Jake: Split into two groups, split into two groups.
Katrina: 分两拨
Katrina: Split into two groups.
Tasha:  5-11
Tasha: 5-11.
Katrina:  5-11跟1-4
Katrina: 5-11 and 1-4.
Tasha: 你是1-4和12对吗
Tasha: You're 1-4 and 12, right?
Katrina:  啊可以可以
Katrina: Yeah, sure.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay
Katrina:  1-4和12
Katrina: 1-4 and 12
Katrina:  走我俩去哪个
Katrina: Let's go, which one do we go to?
Jake: 这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 这是这是什么组
Jake: What group is this?
Jake: 这是什么组
Tasha: 这是食材组
Tasha: This is the ingredients group.
Katrina: 我我去
Katrina: I'm going.
Katrina:  我们俩去买酒吧
Katrina: We'll go buy the alcohol.
Tasha: 这是酒组
Tasha: This is the alcohol group.
Jake: 酒组行行好
Jake: Alcohol group, okay, alright.
Katrina:  那你们还要一个过来不
Katrina: Do you need someone else to join?
Katrina:  12123456 我俩再加一个
Katrina: 12123456, we can add one more.
Lucia: 33好了那就
Lucia: 33, that's it.
Katrina:  33
Katrina: 33.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina: 他肯定要
Katrina: He definitely wants to join.
Jake: 行那怎么说
Jake: Alright, how about this?
Jake:对食材
Jake: Yes, the ingredients.
Katrina:  他是你们的主主星
Katrina: He's your main star.
Katrina:  组合里你俩选
Katrina: You two pick from the group.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Alice: 我我我跟他绑定
Alice: I'll team up with him.
Lucia: 我都都行
Lucia: I'm okay with anything.
Lucia: 那我来好了
Lucia: I'll do it then.
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿嘿好
Tasha: Hehehe, alright.
Katrina:  好反正你还比较懂调酒
Katrina: Good, since you know about mixing drinks.
Tasha: 对你们三个都是懂酒的
Tasha: Right, you three know about alcohol.
Lucia: 也没有那么
Lucia: Not that much.
Lucia: 我我我没有那么懂了其实
Lucia: Actually, I don't know that much.
Jake: 确实我是一点都不懂
Jake: Honestly, I don't know anything.
Jake: 我咖啡都不喝
Jake: I don't even drink coffee.
Katrina:  朗姆
Katrina: Rum.
Jake: 都没法买啥也没法
Jake: Can't buy anything, can't do anything.
Jake: 但是好像食品
Jake: But it seems like food.
Jake: 我也不懂
Jake: I don't know either.
Lucia: 我可以申请买个水果
Lucia: Can I apply to buy some fruit?
Tasha: 买
Tasha: Buy.
Tasha: 想吃什么你可以跟我说啊
Tasha: Whatever you want to eat, just tell me.
Lucia: 随便只要是个水果就行
Lucia: Anything, as long as it's fruit.
Katrina:  我想要那个青提
Katrina: I want that green grape.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈真的
Lucia: Hahaha, really?
Katrina:  我要那个青提
Katrina: I want that green grape.
Katrina:  阳光玫瑰那种
Katrina: The Shine Muscat kind.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 好那我那我也吃这个就可以了
Lucia: Okay, then I'll have this one too.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Katrina:  你的青梅青梅啊
Katrina: Your green plum, green plum.
Tasha: 啊这个会买的
Tasha: Ah, I'll buy this one.
Katrina:  青梅啊啊
Katrina: Green plum, ah, ah.
Tasha: 您觉得买一盒还是买两盒呢
Tasha: Do you think we should buy one box or two?
Jake: 买买哎我看看啊
Jake: Buy, buy, let me see.
Tasha: 我觉得可以买两盒
Tasha: I think we can buy two boxes.
Tasha: 一盒做蛋糕一盒也吃
Tasha: One box for making cake, and one for eating.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Alice:这个长得不好换一个
Alice: This one doesn't look good, let's change it.
Jake: 是不是买两盒
Jake: Should we buy two boxes?
Jake: 两盒都吃了呀
Jake: Are we going to eat both boxes?
Lucia: 没事他们不知道这个是干啥用的
Lucia: It's okay, they don't know what this is for.
Alice:这个吧
Alice: How about this one?
Alice: 这个大
Alice: This one's big.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 你们可以商量商量
Jake: You guys can discuss it.
Jake: 为什么选这个
Jake: Why did you choose this one?
Tasha: 这个草莓好吃
Tasha: These strawberries are tasty.
Jake: 不是就是为什么这个
Jake: No, I mean, why this one?
Alice: 因为这个有白的感觉没有很
Alice: Because this one looks whiter, it doesn't look very...
Tasha: 他这个要买
Tasha: He wants to buy this one.
Alice:饱满成熟
Alice: Full and ripe.
Tasha: 你看他这个虽然小但他多
Tasha: Look, this one is smaller but there are more of them.
Tasha: 这个虽然大但他少
Tasha: This one is bigger but there are fewer of them.
Alice: 他多吗
Alice: Are there more?
Tasha: 对对这个是多两排这个是少两排的
Tasha: Yes, yes, this one has two more rows, this one has two fewer rows.
Tasha: 我经常吃
Tasha: I eat them often.
Tasha: 对，他少两排
Tasha: Yes, this one has fewer rows.
Alice:啊没发现
Alice: Ah, I didn't notice.
Tasha: 他少两排
Tasha: It has fewer rows.
Tasha: 你看你没事
Tasha: Look, you didn't realize.
Alice:诶一排还是两排啊
Alice: Hey, is it one row or two?
Jake: 他这个他这个挡着
Jake: This one, this one is blocking it.
Jake: 是有还是没有啊
Jake: Is it there or not?
Tasha: 呃有
Tasha: Uh, yes.
Alice: 哦这是5排这是6排
Alice: Oh, this is row 5 and this is row 6.
Tasha: 呃就是一排两排
Tasha: Uh, it's just one row, two rows.
Jake:哦没那么狗是吧
Jake: Oh, it's not that bad, right?
Tasha: 这是一排两排三排四排对对
Tasha: This is row one, row two, row three, row four, yeah.
Alice: 哦嗯那么要大的还是要小的呢
Alice: Oh, hmm, do you want a big one or a small one?
Tasha: 那肯定要大的
Tasha: Definitely a big one.
Alice:大的吧
Alice: A big one, right?
Tasha: 这就是他们刚刚点名的
Tasha: These are the ones they just mentioned.
Alice: 阳光玫瑰
Alice: Sunshine Rose.
Alice: 找一个果形饱满的
Alice: Find one that's full and plump.
Tasha: 我觉得这个比较多
Tasha: I think this one has more.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 都500克吧
Alice: They're all 500 grams, right?
Tasha: 但好像都是500克
Tasha: But they all seem to be 500 grams.
Tasha: 那我选他吧
Tasha: Then I'll choose this one.
Tasha: 你觉得呢
Tasha: What do you think?
Tasha: 你有没有心仪的
Tasha: Do you have a favorite?
Alice: 我觉得长得都差不多
Alice: I think they all look similar.
Tasha: 那这个吧
Tasha: Then this one.
Alice: 他们家评论还可以
Alice: Their reviews are not bad.
Jake: 我看看这都多少钱
Jake: Let me see how much these cost.
Tasha: 不能吃现切的
Tasha: You can't eat freshly cut ones.
Jake: 我看看都多少钱
Jake: Let me see how much they cost.
Jake: 我就看一眼
Jake: I'll just take a look.
Jake: 多少钱我比比价
Jake: I'll compare the prices.
Jake: 为什么不能吃现切的
Jake: Why can't you eat freshly cut ones?
Tasha: 因为你没听过前段时间现切的事吗
Tasha: Because haven't you heard about the freshly cut ones recently?
Tasha: 把坏的切掉把好的然后
Tasha: They cut off the bad parts and then...
Jake: 好的就在这卖了
Jake: The good ones are sold here.
Jake: 坏的就在这卖了
Jake: The bad ones are sold here too.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Jake: 给世界人民涨涨知识
Jake: Let's educate the world.
Tasha: 还有什么让我们看一看
Tasha: What else, let’s take a look.
Tasha: 水果采购
Tasha: Fruit shopping.
Tasha: 蓝莓要吗
Tasha: Do we need blueberries?
Jake:蓝莓可以要
Jake: Blueberries are fine.
Alice: 蓝莓在门口那个大果
Alice: Blueberries are at the entrance, the big ones.
Alice: 需要凤梨吗
Alice: Do we need pineapples?
Tasha: 你喜欢吃可以拿一盒
Tasha: If you like it, you can take a box.
Alice:我觉得一般
Alice: I think it's just okay.
Tasha: 我也觉得一般
Tasha: I think it's just okay too.
Alice:有没有买了几种啊
Alice: Did you buy a few kinds?
Alice: 这个是用来吃的
Alice: This one is for eating.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Alice: 这个是用来摆的
Alice: This one is for display.
Tasha: 这个也可以用来摆
Tasha: This one can also be for display.
Alice: 再加一个黄的
Alice: Let's add a yellow one.
Tasha: 黄的芒果
Tasha: A yellow mango.
Alice:芒果
Alice: Mango.
Jake:菠萝
Jake: Pineapple.
Alice: 芒果
Alice: Mango.
Tasha: 菠萝不太好放在甜品里
Tasha: Pineapple isn't good for desserts.
Jake: 甜品哦~
Jake: Desserts, huh~
Alice: 买这个吧
Alice: Let's buy this.
Alice:这个他们家的
Alice: This one from their store.
Alice:那种
Alice: That kind.
Tasha: 可以呀
Alice: 那种叫什么来着
Alice: What is that called again?
Jake: 不是不能现切吗
Jake: Can't we cut it on the spot?
Jake: 到底能不能现切
Jake: Can we cut it on the spot or not?
Tasha: 其实我觉得现切的不太好
Tasha: Actually, I don't think freshly cut ones are that good.
Tasha: 你可以买那个让他帮你现场切
Tasha: You can buy it and ask them to cut it for you on the spot.
Jake: 那可以啊
Jake: That's fine.
Jake: 但是买凤梨不是不是
Jake: But when buying pineapples...
Jake:放不放甜点里
Jake: Should we put it in the dessert?
Tasha: 不放
Tasha: No.
Jake: 啊就自己吃
Jake: Oh, just for eating?
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Jake:好让他切吧
Jake: Okay, let them cut it.
Jake: 给他拍一个特写一个切的
Jake: Take a close-up shot of them cutting it.
Jake: 可乐
Jake: Cola.
Tasha: 你看他可以呼叫店员帮你切
Tasha: Look, you can call the staff to help you cut it.
Jake: 好切
Jake: Okay, cut it.
Tasha: 挑的话挑那种刺比较尖的
Tasha: When choosing, pick the ones with sharper spikes.
Jake: 挑比较大格子比较大
Jake: Choose the ones with bigger grids.
Jake: 这个我会
Jake: I know how to do this.
Jake: 这个我在新加坡
Jake: I did this in Singapore.
Jake: 这个我在新加坡切过
Jake: I cut this in Singapore.
Tasha: 你觉得这两个哪个好
Tasha: Which one do you think is better?
Jake:这个我看看
Jake: Let me take a look.
Jake:这个吧
Jake: This one.
Jake: 这就下班了
Jake: Are we done for the day?
Jake: 这才几点
Jake: What time is it?
Jake: 那我们现在谁跟我说来着
Jake: So, who was talking to me just now?
Jake: 就不让我们切
Jake: They won't let us cut?
Jake: 我们没有收钱哦
Jake: We didn't charge any money though.
Tasha: 那他什么时候开始切
Tasha: When will he start cutting then?
Tasha: 行吧那我们买个这个吧
Tasha: Alright, let's buy this one.
Lucia: 拿一个也行吧
Lucia: One is fine, right?
Tasha: 你挑一个
Tasha: You pick one.
Jake: 行吧那就至于大家信他一个吧
Jake: Okay, let's just trust him with this one.
Tasha: 买一个这个才8块钱
Tasha: Buying this one is only 8 yuan.
Tasha: 我觉得小台芒是芒果里面最甜的
Tasha: I think the small Thai mangoes are the sweetest.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 你挑挑哪个
Tasha: You pick one.
Tasha: 是6个的啊
Tasha: It's a pack of six.
Tasha: 我刚看到这个是6个但他这有霉点
Tasha: I just saw this pack has six but there are some mold spots.
Tasha: 所以要挑一个
Tasha: So we need to pick another one.
Tasha: 另一个6个的
Tasha: Another pack of six.
Alice:小台芒的吗
Alice: The small Thai mangoes?
Tasha: 发挥你的眼睛对
Tasha: Use your eyes, yes.
Alice: 小台芒比较甜比较软
Alice: The small Thai mangoes are sweeter and softer.
Tasha: 对小台芒
Tasha: Yes, small Thai mangoes.
Jake:这是6个吗
Jake: Are there six here?
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Tasha: OK看看水果就买齐了吧
Tasha: Okay, looks like we got all the fruits.
Tasha: 下一步是
Tasha: Next step is...
Tasha: 牛奶无菌蛋牛奶
Tasha: Milk, pasteurized eggs, milk.
Alice:这是你外送的
Alice: This is what you delivered?
Jake: 对我在拍他
Jake: Yeah, I'm filming him.
Alice:这款还挺好喝的
Alice: This one tastes pretty good.
Tasha: 我我也觉着
Tasha: Yeah, I think so too.
Tasha: 椰子水拿一瓶吧
Tasha: Let's grab a bottle of coconut water.
Tasha: 但在哪呢
Tasha: But where is it?
Alice:椰子水买那个吧
Alice: Let's get that coconut water.
Tasha: 这个哎
Tasha: Oh, this one.
Tasha: 这个贵了一点
Tasha: This one's a bit expensive.
Tasha: 买这个
Tasha: Let's buy this.
Alice: 这个就是那个便宜的
Alice: This is the cheap one.
Tasha: 这个是便
Tasha: This is chea-
Tasha: 是便宜的啊
Tasha: It's the cheap one.
Tasha: 他们都是一升
Tasha: They're all one liter.
Alice: 这怎么是8块9了
Alice: Why is this 8.9 yuan?
Tasha: 对他们都是一升
Tasha: Yeah, they're all one liter.
Tasha: 但他只要8块9
Tasha: But this one is only 8.9 yuan.
Tasha: 他还更贵
Tasha: It's even more expensive.
Alice: 果汁哦
Alice: Juice.
Alice: 果汁是他们买
Alice: They bought the juice.
Tasha: 还有东西吗
Tasha: Anything else?
Tasha: 牛奶无菌蛋
Tasha: Milk and sterile eggs.
Alice: 牛奶买了吗
Alice: Did we buy milk?
Tasha: 牛奶买了
Tasha: Yes, we bought milk.
Alice: 两盒够不够
Alice: Are two boxes enough?
Tasha: 够了吧
Tasha: Should be enough.
Alice:无菌蛋
Alice: Sterile eggs.
Tasha: 鸡蛋鸡蛋蛋
Tasha: Eggs, eggs.
Jake:淡奶油在什么地方
Jake: Where's the whipping cream?
Tasha: 淡奶油在
Tasha: The whipping cream is...
Alice: 奶油应该在酸奶这边
Alice: The cream should be near the yogurt.
Alice: 是差不多的地吧
Alice: Around there, right?
Tasha: 我觉得差不多在冰柜这里
Tasha: I think it's near the freezer.
Tasha: 你好淡奶油在哪里有
Tasha: Excuse me, where's the whipping cream?
Tasha: 哪里
Tasha: Where?
Tasha: 只有喷射的吗
Tasha: Only the spray kind?
Tasha: 好谢谢啊
Tasha: Okay, thank you.
Jake: 哈喽
Jake: Hello.
Alice: 安佳的吗
Alice: Is it Anchor brand?
Tasha: 是的但他比网上还贵
Tasha: Yes, but it's more expensive than online.
Tasha: 他没有嗯
Tasha: They don't have it.
Jake: 我来瞅瞅你们买的啥
Jake: Let me see what you bought.
Jake: 你们看起来进度一般了
Jake: You guys seem to be making slow progress.
Katrina:  嗯没找到饮料
Katrina: Yeah, we couldn't find the drinks.
Shure:  是要我们大买特买那个意思吗
Shure: Are you telling us to buy a lot?
Lucia: 他买了椰子水
Lucia: He bought coconut water.
Lucia: 刚好我们不用买了啊
Lucia: So we don't need to buy it now.
Katrina:  哦他们买了椰子水
Katrina: Oh, they bought coconut water.
Katrina:  是要用椰奶还是椰子水啊
Katrina: Do we need coconut milk or coconut water?
Lucia: 呃其实最好是椰奶
Lucia: Um, ideally coconut milk.
Lucia: 但是咱们也没有那么那个啥嘛
Lucia: But we're not that, you know.
Shure:  椰奶和椰子水完全两个味啊
Shure: Coconut milk and coconut water taste completely different.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Tasha: 喂
Tasha: Hello?
Tasha: 我暂时还不在 你
Tasha: I'm not here right now, you...
Tasha: 要不明天再
Tasha: How about we do it tomorrow...
Tasha: 我明天再去拿行吗
Tasha: Can I pick it up tomorrow?
Tasha: 好谢谢
Tasha: Okay, thanks.
Alice: 选好了吗
Alice: Have you decided?
Tasha: 好吧价格差不多呢
Tasha: Well, the prices are about the same.
Alice: 买两个
Alice: Buy two.
Tasha: 你看网上才卖12块五
Tasha: Look, it's only 12.5 online.
Alice: 是这家的吗
Alice: Is it from this store?
Tasha: 是这个
Tasha: Yes, this one.
Jake:奶油找着了吗
Jake: Did you find the cream?
Alice: 但是它的包装不一样
Alice: But the packaging is different.
Tasha: 好吧它是安佳
Tasha: Well, this one's Anchor.
Jake:就这个
Jake: Just this one.
Tasha: 它是雀巢
Tasha: This one's Nestle.
Alice: 安佳会比较贵
Alice: Anchor is more expensive.
Tasha: 贵了10块钱一瓶
Tasha: It's 10 yuan more per bottle.
Tasha: 如果说这一瓶可以做6个纸杯蛋糕的话
Tasha: If one bottle can make six cupcakes...
Alice: 我们得做多少个
Alice: How many do we need to make?
Tasha: 6个太贵了
Tasha: Six is too expensive.
Tasha: 这120块钱我觉得就要大差大要
Tasha: I think 120 yuan is really pushing it.
Tasha: 买先买4瓶吧
Tasha: Let's buy four bottles first.
Alice: 我们这个现在在网上买还来的及吗
Alice: Can we still buy it online in time?
Tasha: 也可以吧
Tasha: Maybe.
Tasha: 蓝风车
Tasha: Blue Windmill.
Jake: 这还能小时达吗还是明天达
Jake: Can this be delivered within the hour or by tomorrow?
Tasha: 是啊我要看看嘛
Tasha: Yeah, I need to check.
Jake:你这可以选的诶
Jake: You can choose, you know.
Tasha: 一件
Tasha: One item.
Tasha: 你看他这个小时达的哎
Tasha: Look, this one can be delivered within the hour.
Tasha: 五棵松店呀
Tasha: Wukesong store.
Tasha: 就这个
Tasha: This one.
Alice: 你知道五颗松在哪吗
Alice: Do you know where Wukesong is?
Tasha: 不知道呵呵
Tasha: No, haha.
Tasha: 我选的地址可能在那哦
Tasha: The address I chose might be there.
Tasha: 那拿三个吧
Tasha: Let's just get three then.
Tasha: 在我学校呢
Tasha: At my school
Alice: 在另一边
Alice: On the other side
Jake: 我帮你拿
Jake: I'll help you carry it
Alice:奶盖
Alice: Milk cap
Tasha: 奥就在这买吧
Tasha: Oh, let's just buy it here
Lucia: 谢谢你
Lucia: Thank you
Jake: 不用谢
Jake: No problem
Alice: 这好可爱这是什么
Alice: This is so cute, what is it?
Tasha: 如果少了可能还要再买
Tasha: If it's not enough, we might need to buy more
Jake: 那就网上买
Jake: Then buy it online
Tasha: 可能吧
Tasha: Maybe
Jake:行啊可以网上下个单呗
Jake: Yeah, you can place an order online
Jake: 不要紧啊
Jake: It's fine
Tasha: 啊对如果是22号那天的话可以提前在网上买就行了
Tasha: Ah, right, if it's for the 22nd, we can just buy it online in advance
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right
Jake:然后下单
Jake: Then place an order
Jake:22号那一天
Jake: On the 22nd
Tasha: 不是说那天要做蛋糕吗
Tasha: Didn't we say we were making a cake that day?
Alice:还早嘛
Alice: It's still early
Tasha: 谢谢
Tasha: Thanks
Jake: 厉害你这个
Jake: You're awesome
Jake: 这戴个帽子就把头发挡住了
Jake: Wearing a hat like that hides your hair
Tasha: 然后要什么来着鸡蛋
Tasha: And what do we need, eggs?
Alice: 对无菌蛋
Alice: Yes, sterile eggs
Tasha: 鸡蛋
Tasha: Eggs
Tasha: 糖盐
Tasha: Sugar, salt
Tasha: 奶粉咖啡冻奶油薄荷保鲜膜
Tasha: Milk powder, coffee, whipped cream, mint, cling film
Tasha: 蛋挞皮草莓
Tasha: Tart crusts, strawberries
Tasha: 美文纸为什么也是我们买
Tasha: Why are we also buying parchment paper?
Tasha: 金针菇3-4个
Tasha: Enoki mushrooms, 3-4 of them
Tasha: 松花蛋娃娃菜
Tasha: Preserved eggs, baby bok choy
Tasha: 记住了吗
Tasha: Remembered everything?
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go
Jake: 娃娃菜走
Jake: Baby bok choy, let's go
Jake: 哈哈你哈哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, you, hahaha
Tasha: 诶鸡蛋
Tasha: Hey, eggs
Katrina:  这是葡萄吗
Katrina: Are these grapes?
Alice:无菌蛋吗
Alice: Sterile eggs?
Tasha: 买鸡蛋送松花蛋
Tasha: Buy eggs, get preserved eggs
Tasha: 刚好哎
Tasha: Perfect timing
Jake: 诶刚好啊
Jake: Hey, just in time
Tasha: 是无菌的吗
Tasha: Is it sterile?
Alice: 鲜鸡蛋吧
Alice: Fresh eggs, right?
Tasha: 啊鲜鸡蛋也可以吧
Tasha: Ah, fresh eggs should be fine too
Jake: 你们家离高邮远吗
Jake: Is your place far from Gaoyou?
Jake: 高邮
Jake: Gaoyou
Tasha: 高邮
Tasha: Gaoyou
Jake: 啊你们家离那远
Jake: Ah, your place is far from there
Alice: 高邮鸭蛋哦
Alice: Gaoyou salted duck eggs
Alice: 咸鸭蛋
Alice: Salty duck eggs
Tasha: 不远不远
Tasha: Not far, not far
Jake:不远
Tasha: 你们家也不远啊
Tasha: Your place isn't far either
Jake:啊对确实
Jake: Ah yes, indeed
Alice:基本上都是鲜
Alice: Mostly fresh
Alice: 哦那个是可生食的
Alice: Oh, those can be eaten raw
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes
Tasha:啊 这呢我觉得可生食的买一点就行了
Tasha: Ah, I think we just need to buy a bit of the raw ones
Tasha: 然后再买一盒这个也可以了
Tasha: And then buy a box of these
Tasha: 这个就买
Tasha: Just buy this
Tasha: 呃做那个提拉米苏
Tasha: Uh, for making Tiramisu
Alice:提拉米苏用
Alice: For Tiramisu
Tasha: 对然后别的都可以用
Tasha: Yes, and the others can use
Tasha: 用非无菌的蛋
Tasha: Non-sterile eggs
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Alice: 熟的就行
Alice: As long as they're cooked
Jake: 无菌蛋无菌蛋是什么意思
Jake: What does sterile egg mean?
Tasha: 无菌蛋就是你现在直接可以吃下去
Tasha: It means you can eat it directly now
Jake: 就是他为什么叫无菌蛋
Jake: Why is it called a sterile egg?
Tasha: 因为有
Tasha: Because there are
Tasha: 因为他就是不会有细菌吧
Tasha: Because it doesn't have bacteria, I guess
Tasha: 可能
Tasha: Maybe
Alice:是什么沙门氏菌什么的
Alice: Something like salmonella or whatever
Jake: 他就是这个鸡比较牛逼
Jake: So the chicken is awesome
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or
Alice: 就是他的那个饲养流程比较那啥
Alice: It's more about their feeding process
Alice: 控制比较严
Alice: Strict control
Jake: 刚生下来然后就被保存起来了之类的
Jake: They're preserved immediately after being laid or something
Alice: 具体的不是很清楚
Alice: Not exactly sure on the details
Jake: OK OK行
Jake: OK OK, got it.
Tasha: 无菌蛋牛奶白糖盐
Tasha: Sterilized eggs, milk, sugar, salt.
Lucia: 这个不是太大了吗
Lucia: Isn't this too big?
Alice: 调味料那边
Alice: The seasonings are over there.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Alice: 哦那边是蔬菜
Alice: Oh, the vegetables are over there.
Alice: 买点菌菇类的
Alice: Let's buy some mushrooms.
Tasha: 哇这是什么茶
Tasha: Wow, what kind of tea is this?
Alice: 黄瓜花也能吃吗
Alice: Can you eat cucumber flowers?
Jake: 买 买
Jake: Buy it, buy it.
Alice: 为什么娃娃菜这么贵
Alice: Why is baby cabbage so expensive?
Jake:你要买吗
Jake: Do you want to buy it?
Alice: 没有普通的吗
Alice: Don't they have regular ones?
Tasha: 老板你有想吃的吗
Tasha: Boss, do you want anything?
Alice: 这是大白菜啊
Alice: This is napa cabbage.
Jake:我把我想吃的人都招过来了 会做吗
Jake: I gathered everyone I want to eat with, can they cook?
Tasha: 就买这个娃娃菜买了吗
Tasha: So, are we buying this baby cabbage?
Jake:会做好吃的菜的人都招过来了
Jake: I gathered everyone who can cook well.
Jake: 这玩意他买了吗
Jake: Did he buy this thing?
Alice: 没有但是我感觉好贵啊他
Alice: No, but I feel like it's so expensive.
Tasha: 是的好贵啊
Tasha: Yes, it's really expensive.
Tasha: 但是看着也挺好嫩的怎么这么贵去我家地里摘吧
Tasha: But it looks so tender, why is it so expensive? Let's pick some from my farm.
Alice: 主要是他一煮他就很小啦
Alice: The main thing is it shrinks a lot when you cook it.
Tasha: 很小哈哈
Tasha: It becomes really small, haha.
Tasha: 那拿点上海青
Tasha: Let's get some Shanghai greens.
Tasha: 上海青才一块钱哈哈
Tasha: Shanghai greens are only one yuan, haha.
Alice: 但是他没那个味
Alice: But it doesn't have that flavor.
Alice: 让我找一下
Alice: Let me look for it.
Alice: 要不然买成这个
Alice: How about we get this instead?
Alice: 我们我们可以我们把帮
Alice: We can, we can, let's...
Tasha: 也可以
Tasha: That works too.
Jake: 为什么这个不行
Jake: Why can't we get this one?
Alice: 因为那个比较贵
Alice: Because it's more expensive.
Tasha: 这个多少钱
Tasha: How much is this?
Alice: 要不然我们
Alice: Or we could...
Jake:他为什么贵啊
Jake: Why is it expensive?
Jake: 这个多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Alice: 白菜能贵到哪
Alice: How expensive can cabbage be?
Alice: 一千 1千克的话
Alice: If it's 1 kilogram...
Alice:白菜
Alice: Cabbage...
Alice:姜
Alice: Ginger
Tasha: 没有价格怎么回事
Tasha: Why is there no price?
Alice:这是杭白菜吗
Alice: Is this Hangzhou cabbage?
Tasha: 你去那扫个码就知道了
Tasha: Just scan the code there and you'll know.
Alice: 那个十一
Alice: That one is eleven.
Alice: 并且两份也不太够
Alice: And two servings are still not enough.
Alice: 买个这个
Alice: Let's get this one.
Jake: 买鸡蛋了
Jake: Bought eggs.
Jake: 买了无菌蛋
Jake: Bought sterilized eggs.
Shure:  我们买了两个火锅底料
Shure: We bought two hot pot bases.
Jake: 火锅底料
Jake: Hot pot base.
Katrina: 没有桃汁啊
Katrina: There's no peach juice?
Shure:  完了我们j人崩溃了
Shure: Oh no, we're all freaking out.
Jake: 我们好像我们我们分到了个
Jake: Seems like we got a...
Shure: 气的跳脚脚了
Shure: Jumping with anger.
Jake: 什么奇怪的任务来着
Jake: ...weird task.
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Shure: 扎死人
Shure: So frustrating.
Alice: 美纹纸
Alice: Masking tape.
Katrina: 普通的品牌都没有吗
Katrina: Don't they have regular brands?
Jake:美纹纸美纹纸是什么东西
Jake: What is masking tape?
Alice:美纹纸这有吗
Alice: Do they have masking tape here?
Katrina:  美文纸美文纸
Katrina: Masking tape, masking tape.
Lucia:美纹纸这这里面能买到吗
Lucia: Can we buy masking tape here?
Jake: 美纹纸是什么东西
Jake: What is masking tape?
Katrina: 就贴墙上不留痕的那贴纸
Katrina: It's that tape that doesn't leave marks on walls.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 要不直接上网买吧
Katrina: Maybe just buy it online.
Alice:再买两个
Alice: Let's buy two more.
Katrina: 跟那海报一起嘛嗯
Katrina: Together with the poster, yeah.
Katrina:  跟那个美纹纸很便宜
Katrina: Masking tape is cheap.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 嗯啊我觉得文具店也会有
Tasha: Hmm, I think stationery stores might have it.
Katrina: 冰块模具还没买
Katrina: We still haven't bought the ice mold.
Alice:要不然我们买大白菜吧
Alice: How about we buy napa cabbage?
Tasha: 好呀
Tasha: Sure.
Alice:然后我们把嫩的部分给它扔进去
Alice: Then we'll throw the tender parts in.
Tasha: 可以呀 可以
Tasha: Sounds good, sounds good.
Jake:跳舞了
Jake: Dancing.
Tasha: 踩到他了哈哈
Tasha: Stepped on him, haha.
Tasha: 哦这什么
Tasha: Oh, what's this?
Alice:槐花你吃过吗
Alice: Have you ever eaten locust flowers?
Tasha: 吃春菜
Tasha: Eat spring vegetables.
Alice: 对槐花你吃过吗
Alice: Yes, locust flowers, have you eaten them?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Alice: 这可以炒可以做包子
Alice: They can be stir-fried or used in buns.
Tasha: 天哪
Tasha: Oh my God.
Alice:很好吃甜甜的
Alice: They're really delicious, sweet.
Jake:啥意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake:我研究研究
Jake: I'll look into it.
Alice:就是这个是一种可以吃的东西
Alice: It's just something edible.
Tasha: 金针菇买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy enoki mushrooms?
Alice: 买了买了
Alice: Yes, yes.
Jake:这为什么撒了呀
Jake: Why did it spill?
Alice:从缝里掉出来了
Alice: It fell out of the gap.
Tasha: 那你吃啊快别浪费
Tasha: Then eat it quickly, don't waste it.
Alice:不是这不能生吃
Alice: No, you can't eat it raw.
Jake:哈哈哈下毒
Jake: Hahaha, poison him.
Alice: 没事不要告诉他
Alice: It's fine, don't tell him.
Alice: 让他吃也行
Alice: Let him eat it, it's okay.
Jake:那他吃了会怎么样呢
Jake: What happens if he eats it?
Alice: 不好吃
Alice: It won't taste good.
Jake:主要是不好吃是吧
Jake: The main thing is it won't taste good, right?
Tasha:那我买点 调味料还有胡椒粉味精糖和盐
Tasha: Then I'll buy some seasoning, pepper powder, MSG, sugar, and salt.
Alice:盐
Alice: Salt.
Alice:嗯得找一个专门那啥的
Alice: Yeah, we need to find a special one.
Jake:槐花呀
Jake: Locust flowers, right?
Alice:你吃过吗
Alice: Have you eaten them?
Tasha: 豆芽豆芽可以加进去吗
Tasha: Bean sprouts, can we add bean sprouts?
Jake:我感觉还真吃过
Jake: I feel like I've really eaten them.
Alice:豆芽不可以没啥味
Alice: Bean sprouts can't be added, they have no taste.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 够够够
Tasha: Enough, enough, enough.
Jake:葱姜蒜有吗
Jake: Do we have green onions, ginger, and garlic?
Alice:葱姜蒜
Alice: Green onions, ginger, and garlic.
Tasha: 葱姜蒜超市不送
Tasha: The supermarket doesn't deliver green onions, ginger, and garlic.
Jake:啊超市不送
Jake: Ah, the supermarket doesn't deliver?
Tasha: 会送吧
Tasha: They probably do.
Jake:怎么送啊
Jake: How do they deliver?
Tasha: 要葱姜蒜吗
Tasha: Do you want green onions, ginger, and garlic?
Jake:就就我们买这些东西他就会送葱姜蒜
Jake: When we buy these things, they give us green onions, ginger, and garlic for free.
Tasha: 是啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 够吗他送的
Tasha: Is what they give enough?
Tasha: 我只是觉得他会送
Tasha: I just think they will give it.
Alice:葱怎么卖啊
Alice: How much for green onions?
Jake:我我我我我
Jake: I, I, I, I...
Alice:蒜
Alice: Garlic.
Jake:surprise闻所未闻
Jake: Surprise, never heard of it.
Jake:shocked
Jake: Shocked.
Tasha: 真的假的不是
Tasha: Really, no way.
Jake:不不知道
Jake: Don't know.
Tasha: 你在江苏是不是从来没逛过菜市场
Tasha: Have you never been to a market in Jiangsu?
Jake:菜市场逛过这种超市
Jake: I've been to the market, this kind of supermarket.
Tasha: 菜市场送不送
Tasha: Do they give it at the market?
Jake: 菜市场可以送
Jake: The market can give it.
Jake: 超市不一定
Jake: The supermarket not necessarily.
Alice:买吗
Alice: Should we buy it?
Tasha: 买吧 药 药是吗
Tasha: Let's buy it. Medicine, right?
Alice:我再想想
Alice: Let me think about it.
Alice:需要但是可以不用这么多
Alice: We need it but not so much.
Alice:但是几个人啊
Alice: But how many people?
Tasha: 我觉得我觉得蒜和葱就一个就行了呵呵
Tasha: I think one garlic and one green onion is enough, haha.
Tasha: 这要大葱吗
Tasha: Do we need big green onions?
Tasha: 还是小葱
Tasha: Or small ones?
Alice: 姜可以不要哎
Alice: We can skip the ginger.
Alice:蒜是出味的
Alice: Garlic adds flavor.
Jake:来让人过
Jake: Let people pass.
Tasha: 行那那那就要着吧
Tasha: Alright then, let's get it.
Alice:看看加
Alice: Let's see, add it.
Tasha: 哎那明天有火锅的话
Tasha: Hey, if we have hotpot tomorrow,
Tasha: 要不要买火锅底料和肉菜啊
Tasha: should we buy hotpot base and meat and veggies?
Jake:他们买了底料
Jake: They bought the base.
Jake:肉他们好像没买
Jake: Seems like they didn't buy meat.
Tasha: 那要不要买肉
Tasha: Should we buy meat?
Jake:可以买肉
Jake: We can buy meat.
Jake: 回头对一下
Jake: Let's check later.
Jake: 可以先
Jake: We can first...
Alice:那个您好我们如果买的话会送葱姜蒜
Alice: Excuse me, if we buy, will you give green onions, ginger, and garlic?
Alice:送多少呢大概
Alice: About how much?
Alice:就是消费
Alice: Just for spending.
Alice:不会送吗不会送吗
Alice: Won't they deliver it? Won't they?
Tasha: 有的时候会员满9.9会送啊
Tasha: Sometimes if you're a member and spend over 9.9, they will.
Alice:没有没有被送过哎
Alice: No, I've never had it delivered.
Jake: 啊什么意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake: 我们还我们还满不了9.9
Jake: We still can't spend over 9.9.
Tasha: 呃主要是我们没有会员啊
Tasha: Uh, mainly because we don't have a membership.
Alice:我好像有会员
Alice: I think I have a membership.
Tasha: 你有吗不知道这今天会不会送
Tasha: Do you? I don't know if they'll deliver today.
Tasha: 有被送过
Tasha: It has been delivered before.
Alice:有被送过但不一定是吧
Alice: It has been, but not always, right?
Tasha: 他好像每天
Tasha: It seems like every day...
Alice:但是这也用不了这么多
Alice: But we can't use that much.
Tasha: 嗯没关系做火锅还要用的
Tasha: Hmm, it's okay, we need it for the hot pot.
Tasha: 拿着吧
Tasha: Just take it.
Alice:确实拿吧
Alice: Yeah, just take it.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:你吃板栗仁吗
Alice: Do you eat chestnuts?
Alice: 可以放进去
Alice: We can put them in.
Tasha: 呃都可以
Tasha: Uh, it's up to you.
Tasha: 呃你可以
Tasha: Uh, you can...
Alice: 我怕他弄不熟
Alice: I'm afraid they won't cook properly.
Tasha: 那算了吧
Tasha: Then forget it.
Alice:因为这个比较难煮
Alice: Because they are hard to cook.
Alice:不过也可以放进去提前煮一下
Alice: But we can also cook them a bit beforehand.
Tasha: 这里呢
Tasha: Over here.
Lucia: 限时买赠 买一送一
Lucia: Limited-time offer, buy one get one free.
Jake:哎呀撞着了
Jake: Oh no, I bumped into it.
Lucia: 哎刚好碰到你们
Lucia: Oh, I just ran into you guys.
Katrina:  买完了
Katrina: It's sold out.
Jake:你们
Jake: You guys...
Katrina:  有两个没有
Katrina: There are two left.
Katrina:  没有有两
Katrina: No, there are...
Katrina: 笔没有
Katrina: No pens left.
Alice:调料
Alice: Seasoning.
Katrina:  那去去买火锅的食材是吧
Katrina: Then let's go buy the hot pot ingredients.
Jake:那你们去吧
Jake: You guys go ahead.
Alice:我们买葱蒜了
Alice: We're buying green onions and garlic.
Katrina:  啊葱蒜
Katrina: Oh, green onions and garlic.
Katrina:  那我们去买火锅食材
Katrina: Then we'll go buy the hot pot ingredients.
Jake:肉在那去吧
Jake: The meat is over there, go ahead.
Katrina: 好那那种什么肥牛卷啥的可以
Katrina: Okay, then we need those fatty beef rolls or something.
Tasha: 那我们的进度好慢啊他们都买完了
Tasha: We're so slow, they've already finished shopping.
Shure:  烤肉的也要买一下
Shure: We also need to buy some barbecue stuff.
Alice:我们比较分散呵呵
Alice: We're kind of scattered, haha.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice:不对他们还在买火锅食材呢
Alice: Actually, they're still buying hot pot ingredients.
Alice:调味料在哪边呢
Alice: Where are the seasonings?
Tasha: 调味调味料
Tasha: Seasonings, seasonings.
Tasha: 你看那人聊天去了
Tasha: Look, that person went to chat.
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's okay.
Tasha: 吃什么黑胡椒奥烧烤粉
Tasha: What should we get, black pepper or barbecue powder?
Alice:在这吧但是这啊
Alice: It's here, but, uh...
Alice:但是奥不是这是那种
Alice: But oh, no, this is kind of...
Alice:那是复合的那种
Alice: This is the mixed kind.
Alice:调味料调味料
Alice: Seasonings, seasonings.
Tasha: 调味料
Tasha: Seasonings.
Alice:在这吧
Alice: It's here.
Tasha: 就这么小个柜子
Tasha: Just this tiny shelf?
Alice:这不是略味鲜酱油
Alice: Isn't this light soy sauce?
Alice:感觉调味料是不是应该在这呢
Alice: Shouldn't the seasonings be here?
Alice: 这已经到熟食区了
Alice: We've already reached the deli section.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Alice:是吗
Alice: Is it?
Alice:盐
Alice: Salt.
Tasha: 加碘哪 有人不能吃碘吗
Tasha: Iodized, can anyone not eat iodine?
Alice:盐来了
Alice: Here's the salt.
Alice:碘
Alice: Iodine.
Alice:没人不能吃碘吧
Alice: No one can't eat iodine, right?
Tasha: 那 那调温量
Tasha: Then, the seasonings.
Alice:盐
Alice: Salt.
Alice:黑胡椒
Alice: Black pepper.
Alice:那有没有白胡椒呢
Alice: Do we have white pepper?
Alice:有白胡椒吧
Alice: There should be white pepper.
Alice:辣椒粉
Alice: Chili powder.
Alice:葱姜蒜
Alice: Green onions, ginger, garlic.
Alice:买葱姜蒜还是买葱姜蒜粉呢
Alice: Should we buy fresh green onions, ginger, and garlic or the powder?
Tasha: 诶葱姜蒜粉好像可以啊
Tasha: Hey, the powder sounds good.
Tasha: 但是算了吧
Tasha: But never mind.
Tasha: 因为那个不是还要也要用
Tasha: Because we also need to use the fresh ones.
Alice:糖你买了没
Alice: Did you buy the sugar?
Tasha: 哦对糖在这呢
Tasha: Oh right, the sugar is here.
Alice:哦对
Alice: Oh, right.
Tasha: 我在想买这个便宜的还是贵的
Tasha: I was thinking whether to buy the cheap one or the expensive one.
Jake:有啥差别吗这个糖
Jake: Is there any difference in this sugar?
Tasha: 你看这5.9 这5.5
Tasha: Look, this one is 5.9, this one is 5.5.
Tasha: 好吧可是这个很绵这个很粗
Tasha: Okay, but this one is very fine and this one is coarse.
Jake: 所以哪个好啊
Jake: So which one is better?
Jake:贵4毛钱
Jake: The expensive one is 4 cents more.
Jake: 我觉得这种比较正常
Jake: I think this one is more normal.
Jake:500 这个400克OK
Jake: 500 grams, this one is 400 grams, OK.
Shure: 冷藏储存这个要
Shure: This one needs to be stored in the fridge.
Tasha: 算了就这个吧
Tasha: Forget it, let's go with this one.
Jake:就这个吧
Jake: Let's go with this one.
Jake:这个棉
Jake: This one is fine.
Tasha: 糖盐胡椒粉
Tasha: Sugar, salt, pepper.
Alice: 你得买绵白糖
Alice: You need to buy fine white sugar.
Tasha: 买了绵白糖
Tasha: Bought fine white sugar.
Tasha: 糖盐胡椒粉味精味精是吧
Tasha: Sugar, salt, pepper, MSG, MSG right?
Tasha: 你还要味精这呢
Tasha: You still need MSG, here it is.
Alice:这是鸡精哦
Alice: This is chicken essence.
Alice:这个是味哦盐
Alice: This one is MSG, oh salt.
Tasha: 喂 您
Tasha: Hello, sir.
Tasha: 属实
Tasha: Indeed.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 鸡精
Tasha: Chicken essence.
Tasha: 哦还是买了鸡精是吧没有味精是吧
Tasha: Oh, we still bought chicken essence, no MSG, right?
Alice:没有没有味精
Alice: No, no MSG.
Jake:没有味精
Jake: No MSG.
Tasha: 差不多味精和鸡精差不多
Tasha: Almost the same, MSG and chicken essence are almost the same.
Alice:味精会健康一点
Alice: MSG is a bit healthier.
Tasha: 把鸡精挑
Tasha: Pick the chicken essence.
Alice:鸡精的添加剂多一点
Alice: Chicken essence has more additives.
Jake:哦没关系
Jake: Oh, it's okay.
Jake:活到现在了
Jake: We've lived this long.
Tasha: 金针菇松花蛋娃娃菜都买了
Tasha: Enoki mushrooms, preserved eggs, baby bok choy, all bought.
Alice: 我买过一个午餐肉
Alice: I bought a can of luncheon meat.
Alice:但我不知道够不够
Alice: But I don't know if it's enough.
Tasha: 草莓买了
Tasha: Bought strawberries.
Tasha: 奶油买了
Tasha: Got cream.
Tasha: 薄荷保鲜膜
Tasha: Mint and cling film.
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Tart shells.
Tasha: 奶粉咖啡豆
Tasha: Milk powder and coffee beans.
Tasha: 我已经开始渴了
Tasha: I'm already getting thirsty.
Tasha: 听到这个声音
Tasha: Hearing this sound.
Jake: 买一会喝
Jake: Buy some to drink later.
Tasha: 这买什么来着 咖啡豆
Tasha: What are we supposed to buy again? Coffee beans.
Jake:喝
Jake: Drink.
Jake:咖啡豆
Jake: Coffee beans.
Tasha: 他不知道
Tasha: He doesn't know.
Tasha: 磨咖啡要吗
Tasha: Do we need to grind the coffee?
Jake:咖啡豆在哪买
Jake: Where do we buy coffee beans?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Alice: 咖啡豆这不好买吧
Alice: Coffee beans aren't easy to find, right?
Tasha: 你好这里有咖啡豆卖吗
Tasha: Hi, do you sell coffee beans here?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice:奶粉哦奶粉是他们买吧
Alice: Milk powder, oh, they should buy it, right?
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Alice:奶粉是他们买吗
Alice: Are they supposed to buy the milk powder?
Alice:我们是几到几啊
Alice: What's our range?
Tasha: 我们是5-11
Tasha: We're 5-11.
Alice: 那我们没有买奶粉
Alice: Then we didn't buy the milk powder.
Tasha: 没事其实奶粉不重要
Tasha: It's okay, milk powder isn't that important.
Tasha: 我只想一小一小包而已
Tasha: I just want a small pack anyway.
Jake:丑蛋糕他们在干嘛
Jake: What are they doing with the ugly cake?
Alice:你在找啥呀
Alice: What are you looking for?
Tasha: 咖啡豆
Tasha: Coffee beans.
Alice:蓝胖子
Alice: Blue chubby one.
Alice: 是蓝胖子吧
Alice: It's the blue chubby one, right?
Tasha: 啊太贵了这一罐没必要
Tasha: Ah, this can is too expensive, not necessary.
Jake:水果麦
Jake: Fruit wheat.
Tasha:  哎这有咖啡豆这
Tasha: Oh, there's coffee beans here.
Alice:这都有
Alice: They have everything here.
Tasha: 你觉得买哪个好
Tasha: Which one do you think we should buy?
Tasha: 5 59
Tasha: 5 59.
Alice:咖啡豆他是要干嘛
Alice: What does he want coffee beans for?
Tasha: 他要磨咖
Tasha: He wants to grind coffee.
Alice:那这种是不是
Alice: So, is it this kind?
Tasha: 这是你要的咖啡豆吗
Tasha: Is this the coffee beans you wanted?
Alice: 还是这种的
Alice: Or is it this kind?
Jake:这个今天是他们要做上汤娃娃菜
Jake: Today, they are going to make Bok Choy soup.
Jake:专门给他上汤娃娃菜搞的蔬菜
Jake: These vegetables are specifically for the Bok Choy soup.
Tasha: 不用买
Tasha: No need to buy.
Tasha: 那你明天带吗
Tasha: Are you bringing it tomorrow?
Alice: 你买了吗
Alice: Did you buy it?
Shure: 我买了  啊 对
Shure: Yes, I bought it. Ah, right.
Lucia: 你可以先看一下吗
Lucia: Can you take a look first?
Tasha:这个吗 那行那我就不不拿了
Tasha: This one? Okay, then I won't take it.
Lucia: 现在买的东西
Lucia: The things we bought now.
Tasha: 那呢
Tasha: What about that?
Lucia: 好奇一下你们这边的东西
Lucia: Just curious about your stuff here.
Tasha: 保鲜膜
Tasha: Cling film.
Jake:咖啡豆
Jake: Coffee beans.
Lucia: 我们刚才好像是拿了一盒速溶咖啡
Lucia: We just took a box of instant coffee, I think.
Shure:  我跟他跟他说了
Shure: I told him.
Jake:哦速溶但是这个就慢
Jake: Oh, instant coffee is slower though.
Shure:  咖啡豆的话
Shure: About coffee beans.
Lucia: 就是这个
Lucia: It's this one.
Lucia: 好久不见了 从我回国
Lucia: Long time no see, since I returned home.
Katrina:  你们拿椰奶了吗
Katrina: Did you get coconut milk?
Alice:有椰子水
Alice: There's coconut water.
Shure:  购入一下
Shure: Let's purchase it.
Lucia: mitchposticks怎么还是从德国进口了
Lucia: Why are Mitchposticks still imported from Germany?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Alice: 你们需要吗
Alice: Do you need it?
Katrina:  我在想
Katrina: I'm thinking.
Katrina:  咖啡是不是可以兑一点椰子汁啊
Katrina: Can coffee be mixed with some coconut juice?
Alice:椰奶吗
Alice: Coconut milk?
Alice:不开封的话可以放几天
Alice: If unopened, it can last a few days.
Alice:其实那个大的你开封之后放两三天
Alice: Actually, the large one can last two or three days after opening.
Tasha: 保鲜膜
Tasha: Cling film.
Jake: 我们先对一下吧
Jake: Let's check first.
Katrina: 当时谁跟我说椰奶变质了会中毒
Katrina: Someone told me spoiled coconut milk can be poisonous.
Lucia: 对保鲜膜可以在超市买
Lucia: Yes, cling film can be bought at the supermarket.
Alice:确实
Alice: That's true.
Jake:对一下我们找一个
Jake: Let's check and find one.
Katrina: 就不敢
Katrina: Just don't dare.
Alice:但是嗯嗯我一般一
Alice: But um, I usually...
Katrina: 我确实没有看见他那小盒小盒的
Katrina: I really didn't see those little boxes.
Alice:我一般买这种大的
Alice: I usually buy the big ones.
Tasha: 买咖啡液也行 就不用咖啡粉就不用速溶咖啡调了
Tasha: You can buy coffee liquid too, so you don't need coffee powder or instant coffee.
Katrina: 要么直接叫外卖吧
Katrina: Or we can just order delivery.
Shure:  也行反正都都都行
Shure: That's fine, everything's fine.
Jake:都行都行反正我也不喝咖啡
Jake: Everything's fine, I don't drink coffee anyway.
Shure: 那你今天
Shure: So today...
Jake:哈哈早上不行啊
Jake: Haha, not in the morning.
Katrina: 不知道以为我们工作呢
Katrina: People might think we're working.
Katrina: 这个肉不够吧
Katrina: This meat isn't enough, right?
Katrina:  如果我6个人吃火锅的话
Katrina: If six people are eating hotpot...
Alice:肉在哪啊
Alice: Where's the meat?
Tasha: 这呢
Tasha: It's here.
Katrina: 两盒牛肉
Katrina: Two boxes of beef.
Tasha: 再买点丸子和虾滑
Tasha: Let's buy some meatballs and shrimp paste.
Katrina:  丸子买了虾滑也买了
Katrina: We already bought meatballs and shrimp paste.
Katrina:  我觉得还要拿两盒肉
Katrina: I think we need two more boxes of meat.
Katrina:  青菜也没买哎
Katrina: And we didn't buy any greens.
Lucia: 我们为什么买哦
Lucia: Why are we buying oh...
Lucia: 哦哦蔬菜是吧
Lucia: Oh, vegetables, right.
Jake:确实
Jake: True.
Lucia: 蔬菜哦新到的咸鱼土豆
Lucia: Vegetables, oh, new salted fish and potatoes.
Katrina:  你要吃土豆是吗
Katrina: You want to eat potatoes?
Jake: 土豆好土豆可以
Jake: Potatoes are good.
Jake:土豆可以啊
Jake: Yeah, potatoes are fine.
Lucia: 其实我也喜欢
Lucia: Actually, I like them too.
Katrina: 走吧那我们蔬菜买肉跟青菜
Katrina: Let's go, we'll buy vegetables, meat, and greens.
Jake:咱不是还有那个削土豆皮的那个
Jake: Don't we still have that potato peeler?
Tasha: 那个不是完了小土豆皮奥
Tasha: That was for small potatoes.
Tasha: 芋头没有买
Tasha: We didn't buy taro.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure: 芋头是啥啊
Shure: What's taro?
Lucia: 芋头放火锅吗
Lucia: Do you put taro in hotpot?
Alice:芋头
Alice: Taro.
Tasha: 不是芋泥
Tasha: No, taro paste.
Lucia: 啊okok
Lucia: Ah, okay, okay.
Shure: 芋泥
Shure: Taro paste.
Jake:哎呀这什么东西
Jake: Oh man, what's this?
Lucia: sorry没有跟上这个频道
Lucia: Sorry, I couldn't keep up with the conversation.
Shure: 芋泥
Shure: Taro paste
Katrina: 芋泥芋泥耶
Katrina: Taro paste, taro paste, yay
Alice:芋头放火锅也很好吃
Alice: Taro in hot pot is also delicious
Alice: 那个荔浦芋头
Alice: That Lipu taro
Jake:酱香烤鸭
Jake: Sauce-flavored roast duck
Tasha: 对我是要买荔浦芋头
Tasha: Yes, I want to buy Lipu taro
Shure: 芋芋泥能波波吗
Shure: Can taro paste be boba?
Tasha: 走吧诶不对
Tasha: Let's go, oh wait
Tasha: 好那我们的爆皮刀就有两用了
Tasha: Okay, then our peeling knife has two uses
Jake:哈哈哈走
Jake: Hahaha let's go
Katrina: 哈哈少来这种
Katrina: Haha, don't be like that
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no
Alice:咋了
Alice: What's wrong?
Tasha: 你想吃螺蛳粉吗
Tasha: Do you want to eat snail noodles?
Tasha: 你喜欢吃吗
Tasha: Do you like it?
Jake: 吃什么呀
Jake: Eat what?
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This
Jake: 螺蛳粉啊
Jake: Snail noodles, huh
Jake:嗯呃能吃就没
Jake: Hmm, if it's edible then...
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Jake: 那么没一定要吃
Jake: Then there's no need to definitely eat it
Lucia: 水产品
Lucia: Seafood
Jake: 对没那么想吃
Jake: Right, not that eager to eat it
Lucia: 如果我们想买虾仁的话
Lucia: If we want to buy shrimp
Alice:牵手手我们去买蔬菜吧
Alice: Hold hands, let's go buy vegetables
Jake:就是就是
Jake: Exactly, exactly
Jake:没得吃可以吃一吃
Jake: If there's nothing else, we can eat that
Jake: 可以吃一吃
Jake: We can eat that
Tasha: 谁去买蔬菜他们去买蔬菜
Tasha: Who's going to buy vegetables? They're going to buy vegetables
Alice:我们啊
Alice: Us
Jake:他们他们买蔬菜
Jake: Them, they buy vegetables
Alice:他们买过了吗
Alice: Have they bought it?
Jake:他们买蔬菜
Jake: They buy vegetables
Alice:我们菜不是在那边吗
Alice: Aren't our vegetables over there?
Jake:我我对啊你们他们
Jake: I, I, yes, you, them
Tasha: 他们可能先买肉吧
Tasha: They might buy meat first
Jake: 他们买帝王蟹是吧
Jake: They buy king crab, right?
Tasha: 这个也在资金范围内吗
Tasha: Is that within the budget?
Jake:哈哈不不你们买海鲜吗
Jake: Haha no no, are you buying seafood?
Lucia: 哇哦 我可以吃这个吗
Lucia: Wow, can I eat this?
Jake: 哈哈哈打打招呼吧
Jake: Hahaha, say hi first.
Katrina: 我们的预算可以吃这个吗
Katrina: Can our budget afford this?
Jake: 要不就拍一拍吧要不
Jake: How about we just take a photo?
Jake: 你好
Jake: Hello.
Lucia: 扫描一下
Lucia: Scan it.
Jake: 1,699也还行吧
Jake: 1,699 is not too bad, right?
Alice:您好
Alice: Hi.
Tasha: 那来一只吧
Tasha: Then let's get one.
Lucia: 真的吗可以吃吗
Lucia: Really, can we eat this?
Lucia: 哈哈哈来一只吧
Lucia: Hahaha, let's get one.
Shure:  你千万不要口嗨
Shure: Don't just talk big.
Shure:  我们会当真的好不好
Shure: We'll take it seriously, okay?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:我就说也还行
Jake: I was just saying it's not too bad.
Tasha: 有没有那个转架还是干嘛
Tasha: Do we have that rotating rack or what?
Jake:哈哈哈我没哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, I didn't, hahaha.
Lucia: 也还行我们就把这个也字去掉吧啊
Lucia: It's not too bad, let's just drop the "too."
Lucia: 把还字也去掉
Lucia: And drop the "not."
Lucia: 对对对我们自动识别成型
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, we just identify it automatically.
Alice:我们去找一下荔荔浦芋头吧
Alice: Let's go find some taro from Lilipu.
Alice:但我觉得不一定有
Alice: But I'm not sure if they have it.
Jake:好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Shure: 火锅的蘸料 那一起去买一点
Shure: How about the dipping sauce for hotpot? Let's go buy some.
Alice:蘸料没有
Alice: No dipping sauce.
Lucia: 没有买蘸料
Lucia: We didn't buy any dipping sauce.
Shure:  你们都吃什么碟的火锅一般
Shure: What kind of hotpot sauce do you usually eat?
Alice:麻酱
Alice: Sesame paste.
Shure: 麻酱醋麻酱
Shure: Sesame paste and vinegar.
Tasha: 我要醋
Tasha: I need vinegar.
Lucia: 芝麻酱
Lucia: Sesame paste.
Tasha: 你吃什么碟呢 醋碟
Tasha: What kind of sauce do you use? Vinegar sauce?
Alice:麻酱
Alice: Sesame paste.
Jake:呃麻酱吧
Jake: Uh, sesame paste, I guess.
Alice: 油碟
Alice: Oil sauce.
Jake:你吃什么碟
Jake: What sauce do you use?
Tasha: 你背叛了江苏人
Tasha: You've betrayed the people of Jiangsu.
Jake:其实我在江苏都没怎么吃过火锅
Jake: Actually, I didn't eat much hotpot in Jiangsu.
Jake:我都是上了大学才
Jake: It wasn't until I went to college.
Jake:你是醋碟吗
Jake: You use vinegar sauce?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 我们不应该都和喝恒硕香醋长大的吗
Tasha: Didn't we all grow up drinking Hengshuo vinegar?
Jake:呃就麻将吧
Jake: Uh, let's just go with sesame paste.
Lucia: 对我觉得麻酱其实也可以买小瓶
Lucia: Yeah, I think you can also buy small bottles of sesame paste.
Jake:或者当回江苏人吧
Jake: Or pretend to be from Jiangsu.
Jake:要不吃醋碟也行
Jake: Or just go with vinegar dip.
Tasha: 对啊醋碟
Tasha: Yeah, vinegar dip.
Alice:这是熟食了
Alice: This is cooked food.
Tasha: 对应该在那吧
Tasha: Right, it should be there.
Lucia: 也可以其实火锅还挺省钱的
Lucia: Actually, hot pot can be pretty cost-effective.
Lucia: 嗯只要一堆食材往里一煮就好了哈
Lucia: Yeah, just throw a bunch of ingredients in and cook it, haha.
Jake: 对是的粽子也很省钱哈哈哈哈
Jake: Yes, that's right. Zongzi is also very cost-effective, hahaha.
Alice: 哎呦
Alice: Oh my.
Jake: 买点方便面吧
Jake: Let's buy some instant noodles.
Jake: 算了算了哈哈哈
Jake: Forget it, forget it, hahaha.
Katrina:  后面两天经费不足
Katrina: We don't have enough budget for the next two days.
Katrina:  天天方便面
Katrina: Instant noodles every day.
Tasha: 你觉得芋头会在哪有呢
Tasha: Where do you think we can find taro?
Alice:芋头
Alice: Taro.
Alice:问一下那个啥吧
Alice: Let's ask about that.
Alice:这种魔芋之类的
Alice: Something like konjac.
Tasha: 啊对豆豆制品
Tasha: Oh right, bean products.
Tasha: 但是他们会不会买豆制品呢
Tasha: But will they buy bean products?
Tasha: 那那那我觉得要来一个豆腐
Tasha: Then I think we should get some tofu.
Jake:豆腐
Jake: Tofu.
Jake:包浆豆腐
Jake: Wrapped tofu.
Alice: 我需要魔芋
Alice: I need konjac.
Tasha: 你喜欢吃这种干豆腐还是吃
Tasha: Do you prefer dried tofu or...
Alice:内酯豆腐
Alice: Silken tofu.
Tasha: 内酯豆腐
Tasha: Silken tofu.
Tasha: 这个呢浆水豆腐哎
Tasha: And this, fermented tofu, hey.
Jake:这都什么差别
Jake: What's the difference?
Jake: 这个这个一般
Jake: This one is just okay.
Alice:就是那种老豆腐
Alice: It's just the regular tofu.
Tasha: 那就这种吧
Tasha: Then let's go with this one.
Jake:啊可以
Jake: Ah, okay.
Jake:看起来不错
Jake: Looks good.
Tasha: 鲜豆腐 豆腐皮呢
Tasha: Fresh tofu. What about tofu skin?
Alice:魔芋你要吃那种
Alice: Do you want konjac?
Tasha: 魔芋
Tasha: Konjac.
Alice:对
Alice: Yes.
Tasha: 这个魔芋好奇怪
Tasha: This konjac is so weird.
Alice:这魔芋就是这种的
Alice: Konjac is just like this.
Tasha: 有没有魔芋丝
Tasha: Do they have konjac noodles?
Alice:魔芋丝
Alice: Konjac noodles.
Tasha: 魔芋丝魔芋丝或者魔芋皮都行
Tasha: Konjac noodles or konjac skin, either is fine.
Alice: 就这几种
Alice: These are the few types.
Tasha: 行吧
Tasha: Alright then.
Alice:买这种吧
Alice: Let's buy this one.
Alice:这种比较原生
Alice: This one is more natural.
Tasha: 买这种吗
Tasha: Buy this one?
Tasha: 行那再拿个这个吧
Tasha: Okay, then let's also get this one.
Tasha:3块9
Tasha: It's 3.9 yuan.
Alice: 买这个金针菇吧这个便宜
Alice: Let's buy these enoki mushrooms, they're cheap.
Alice: 这有娃娃菜吗
Alice: Do they have baby cabbages here?
Tasha: 我找到了芋头
Tasha: I found taro.
Tasha: 但是不是荔浦芋头咋办
Tasha: But it's not Lipu taro, what should we do?
Alice:不是荔浦芋头
Alice: It's not Lipu taro.
Alice: 打出来的不细腻
Alice: It won't be smooth when mashed.
Tasha: 怎么办好小啊
Tasha: What should we do? It's so small.
Alice:是那个味道
Alice: That's the taste.
Alice: 这种芋头
Alice: This kind of taro.
Alice:问一下吧
Alice: Let's ask.
Tasha: 吃吃烤地瓜吗
Tasha: Do you want to eat roasted sweet potatoes?
Alice:没有烤箱是吧
Alice: We don't have an oven, right?
Alice: 也可以
Alice: That's okay too.
Alice: 买那种烟薯
Alice: Let's buy those smoked sweet potatoes.
Tasha: 我也这么觉得吧
Tasha: I think so too.
Alice: 这种板栗的也可以
Alice: These chestnut ones are also good.
Tasha: 嗯但这种吃起来有点沙
Tasha: Hmm, but these are a bit sandy when you eat them.
Alice: 都挺好吃的
Alice: They're all pretty tasty.
Tasha: 我想哎
Tasha: I think...
Tasha: 烟薯地瓜
Tasha: Smoked sweet potatoes.
Tasha: 这个可以
Tasha: This one is good.
Tasha: 你觉得买几个
Tasha: How many do you think we should buy?
Alice:至少至少买一个大的吧
Alice: At least get a big one.
Alice: 这个小的
Alice: This small one...
Tasha: 他们这种大的可以切小一点
Tasha: They can cut the big ones into smaller pieces.
Tasha: 就买这个吧
Tasha: Let's just buy this one.
Alice:一大包的
Alice: A big bag.
Alice:小一点的
Alice: A smaller one
Tasha: 这个这种的好熟
Tasha: This kind is well-cooked
Tasha:蜜薯也可以
Tasha: Sweet potatoes are good too
Alice:蜜薯更甜
Alice: Sweet potatoes are sweeter
Alice:哦两个都挺好吃的
Alice: Oh, both are pretty tasty
Alice: 不一样的好吃
Alice: They're delicious in different ways
Tasha: 我觉得蜜薯好吃点吧
Tasha: I think sweet potatoes are tastier
Alice: 葱姜蒜组合
Alice: Scallions, ginger, garlic combo
Tasha: 你好
Tasha: Hello
Tasha: 奥不好意思
Tasha: Oh, sorry
Tasha: 有荔浦芋头吗
Tasha: Do you have Lipu taro?
Tasha: 大的
Tasha: Big ones
Alice: 大的芋头
Alice: Big taro
Alice:啊那种也可以
Alice: Oh, that kind is fine too
Tasha: 啊啊真空包的也可以
Tasha: 可以可以都可以
Tasha: Okay, okay, both are fine
Alice:可以可以可以
Alice: Okay, okay, okay
Alice: 冻一下子更粉
Alice: Freeze it a bit, it gets more powdery
Tasha: 啊对我觉得还冻一下子冻一下还懒得切了
Tasha: Ah, right, I think freezing it a bit makes it easier to cut
Alice:冻一下子更好吃
Alice: Freezing it makes it tastier
Tasha: 没关系我主要在这个没看到 嗯
Tasha: No worries, I mainly didn't see it here, hmm
Tasha: 就没看到没削皮的
Tasha: I didn't see any unpeeled ones
Alice: 荔浦芋头
Alice: Lipu taro
Tasha:那人呢车呢
Tasha: Where are the people and the cars?
Alice:没事待会再偶遇吧
Alice: No worries, let's just run into them later
Alice:诶 那你荔浦芋头要做芋圆吗
Alice: Hey, are you making taro balls with that Lipu taro?
Tasha: 对芋呃芋泥
Tasha: Yes, taro paste
Alice: 那你要做芋圆吗
Alice: So you're making taro balls?
Alice:我可以帮你揉
Alice: I can help you knead it
Alice:我特别喜欢揉的那个
Alice: I really like kneading it
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Tasha: 好嘞
Tasha: Alright
Alice:然后那个荔浦芋头也可以涮火锅
Alice: And the Lipu taro can be used in hotpot too
Tasha: 嗯可以啊
Tasha: Yeah, it can
Alice:如果我们能买的话
Alice: If we can buy it
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sure, we can
Alice: 买个大块的也可以
Alice: We can buy a big piece too
Tasha: 可以买两个大块的
Tasha: We can buy two big pieces
Alice:没事如果红红薯吃不完的话
Alice: No worries, if we can't finish the sweet potatoes
Alice:做成红薯芋啊
Alice: We can make them into sweet potato taro balls
Alice: 不是有那个紫薯粉吗
Alice: Don't we have that purple sweet potato powder?
Tasha: 紫薯粉是用来加颜色的
Tasha: The purple sweet potato powder is for adding color.
Tasha: 他们去干啥去了
Tasha: Where did they go?
Alice:就这个荔浦芋头没什么颜色
Alice: This Lipu taro has no color.
Jake:找你们去了
Jake: They went looking for you.
Tasha: 烤地瓜吗
Tasha: Are they roasting sweet potatoes?
Lucia: 什么叫吊
Lucia: What do you mean by "suspending"?
Jake:烤就放烤箱
Jake: Roast them in the oven.
Alice: 放吧另一个呢
Alice: Put it in, what about the other one?
Tasha: 另什么另一个
Tasha: What other one?
Jake:放烤箱是吧
Jake: Put it in the oven, right?
Tasha: 噢噢烟薯是吗
Tasha: Oh, oh, the smoky sweet potatoes, right?
Jake:土豆
Jake: Potatoes.
Tasha: 好吧我想吃
Tasha: Alright, I want to eat.
Jake: 有土豆吗
Jake: Do we have potatoes?
Jake: 我不用我不用
Jake: I don't need them, I don't need them.
Jake:我乱说的
Jake: I was just saying.
Tasha: 这有土豆
Tasha: There are potatoes here.
Jake:因为刚刚不是提到了吗
Jake: Because you just mentioned it.
Alice:两个
Alice: Two.
Jake:给你加俩土豆
Jake: I'll add two potatoes for you.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay!
Tasha: 你只要爱吃土豆对你就可以加入
Tasha: As long as you love eating potatoes, you can join us.
Tasha: 申请加入我们土门
Tasha: Apply to join our Potato Clan.
Jake:你是土豆
Jake: You are a potato.
Tasha: 呃只需要交298元一年
Tasha: Uh, you just need to pay 298 yuan a year.
Jake:为啥这是什么门
Jake: Why? What is this clan?
Alice:会员费
Alice: Membership fee.
Tasha: 会员式会员费
Tasha: Membership fee, it's a membership fee.
Jake:每天都可以吃土豆吗
Jake: Can I eat potatoes every day?
Jake:呃有什么
Jake: Uh, what else...
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 只要看见我就可以吃
Tasha: As long as you see me, you can eat.
Jake:土豆夹子哦
Jake: Potato clip, oh.
Tasha: 你跟他们说我们买了土豆
Tasha: Tell them we bought potatoes.
Tasha: 还有豆制品豆腐什么的都买了
Tasha: We also bought tofu and other soybean products.
Katrina: 那我们把豆制品要放了吗
Katrina: Should we put the soybean products away?
Alice: 买了魔芋
Alice: We bought konjac.
Lucia: 我们也买了豆腐好像
Lucia: We also bought tofu, I think.
Tasha: 豆腐
Tasha: Tofu
Alice:买了什么豆腐
Alice: What kind of tofu did we buy?
Shure:  豆腐什么
Shure: Tofu what?
Shure:  4拼这种豆制品拼盘
Shure: A platter with 4 types of tofu products.
Alice:哦不一样的东西
Alice: Oh, different things.
Katrina: 你这个你这个是做什么的啊
Katrina: What is this for?
Tasha: 你这个是干的
Tasha: This is dried.
Tasha: 这是鲜的啊
Tasha: This is fresh.
Katrina: 就是放火锅里吃吗
Katrina: Is this for hotpot?
Tasha: 鲜豆腐
Tasha: Fresh tofu.